[Music]
wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
um
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
day
[Music]
you
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
bye
[Music]
now
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
bye
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to panel
from hell
number three my name is fen i will be
your host today
and we are here live in the castle of
counts
the gravenstein in the beautiful city of
ghent that's in flanders
that's in belgium belgium's team that
should have won the euro 2020 but forgot
to do so
and decided to give it to the english or
the italians to be decided on sunday
so why are we here well together we're
gonna discover
what is going to be in patch five and
patch five obviously
is the fifth update for valves gate
three that launched
in early access last october so we're
hitting about
one update every two months which is not
that bad
uh even if i know you want to have us do
it faster
anyways uh we're gonna present the patch
today
in a bit of a different manner than
you're used to we're going to play a
little game today
and you guys are going to be deciding
what's going to happen i'll be your
dungeon master i'll listen to what you
have to tell me
and then uh we are going to guide a
group of adventurers
a group of developers actually who are
going to engage in a very
very dangerous quest as they are going
to try to steal
a scrying orb from a very very dangerous
dangerous castle which belongs to a very
very evil
wizard the count wizard
uh gustav from dragon fell very
dangerous
wizard indeed so the way that is going
to work is that we are going to present
the party to you
and then you are going to choose who
will be the four adventurers that going
to
engage in the adventure and then if you
manage to be successful
we're going to show you all of patch 5's
features if you don't you'll have to
wait until next tuesday
when patch 5 is launching that's going
to be july 13th we wanted to do it today
we know you wanted it today but it
wasn't just quite ready
uh but next tuesday it will definitely
be ready the
developer gods have assured me uh so
uh we are going to show that update if
you manage to get to the exit
at the end of the show but before we get
there we have some adventuring to do
uh without any further ado i would like
you to introduce you
to a party of very very really very
really cool people let's go and have a
look
[Music]
i betcha 50 gold that she's setting us
up
yeah no deal i'm not wasting half a coin
before we even step inside
notice how we never got a name i mean
who gives out gold like that and doesn't
even give a name
[Music]
hey i cut those knuckle bones off and
over myself you know
we should focus on the task at hand yeah
you're the one wasting magic
our benefactor wants us crying more than
we had best get her one
we're on a bit of a time limit so we're
going in
everyone what leaving us to get stabbed
in the back
we need eyes at the camp whoever's going
in we'll have to take the scroll of
teleportation she gave us
look you figure out the details and i
will
scout around
[Music]
now you can't do that again until
tomorrow so what's the real plan
i'm going to get us a bird's-eye view
[Music]
there we are well and good
but we still need to figure out who's
taking the lead i have an idea
let's ask them
[Music]
all right so this is going to be the
group of adventurers that you can pick
today
and so to introduce them we have inner
the warlock we have david the fighter
nick the druid and then we have kelly
the wizard
uh stain the vampire rogue charlotte the
cleric
and of course we have farang the ranger
now you need to pick
one of these four parties and they are
gonna be the first that are going to go
into uh the castle of the evil count
gustav
von drachenfell so let's have it let's
see who you're gonna pick
and then uh yeah we're gonna get started
on our adventure
and may they all survive because we love
them dearly
all right so
what are we gonna get
who is going to be it
okay i'm waiting to hear the results
okay and it is going to be
i believe party b is that correct
i got i'm checking with the direction
party b is that the one
all right we're gonna go with the
fighter and that is going to be
our friend david the thiefling uh we're
gonna go
with a rogue uh who happens to be a
vampire that is going to be stained
we're gonna take a cleric obviously
charlotte the cleric and then we're
gonna have nick the druid with his
awesome shape-shifting skills
all right let's go uh i am ready for
this adventure
uh i hope you guys are ready to uh i've
seen more or less
what the opening looks like but i don't
know what's gonna happen afterwards so
i'm very very very excited about
this happening so let's go in into the
adventure and see
what's going to happen now we also need
a leader actually in the party
uh the leader of the party is somebody
that i'm going to pick
and that is going to be uh well we're
going to go for the oldest man in the
party
and that's going to be our tifflink
david the fighter
all right i'm good to go i don't know
about you guys uh
but uh i am eager to get it started
except ah there we go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right firing firing can you hear me
i'm not faran oh you're david david i'm
sorry i'm so sorry i was thinking of
firing it's because of chat they were
talking
about you're thinking about i'm sorry
david i'm sorry david can you hear me
yes i can hear you
all right okay so word is that this is
pretty dangerous so
you're gonna have to tell me what you
see and tell chat what you see
well uh you can all you can all see what
i'm seeing right so let me describe the
scene here um so we ended up in this
big big room there's a there's a chest
there
i can see an armor there's lots of
swords on that wall i really like swords
uh there's don't touch anything don't
touch anything
okay guys don't touch anything um i also
see a desk and there on the far left
there's also
uh right there there's a there's a
cupboard with with books i think
okay all right okay i'm gonna check it
so yeah there's lots of stuff to see
here all right
you have to tell me you have to tell me
chat where you want them to go all right
so
they want you to i see
i see the word chest pop up they want
you to go and have a look at the chest
that's the first thing they think of
it's loot yeah it looks like it
all right let's go and have a look
always start with the chest to tell you
you know you know what sven i've played
dungeons and dragons games before
and i don't trust this chest one thing
so uh all right chad shall we try to
open the chest
do you want us to open the chest yeah
but i'm the leader i can't open the
chest do you want me to open the chest
yeah okay for all right well okay so i'm
gonna ask
chat chat sorry a chat to oh wait wait
wait wait we'll let them vote if they
are going to
let you open that chest all right and
they're going to pick hold on and what
we're going to do is we're going to let
them we're going to let them vote
who is actually going to open the chest
i was born for this fan stan is very
stain obviously has a rogue it makes a
lot of sense did you bring any lockpicks
leaving tools of course they did you did
all right okay what about you nick did
you bring any teething tools
well you can use mine if you have to uh
charlotte i have a guidance spell my
friend
oh yeah you could guidance you could
guide stain and trying to open that
she doesn't want to get her hands dirty
she just wants to cast spells
all right i'm enough for something okay
do we have that vote going up
uh all right is that vote up
direction i can't see a vote
rogue all right chad has selected that
uh the
rogue should open up the uh the chest
all right shut this very wise watch me
sven
no i i'm watching good night
yeah oh and here is the first new
feature of uh
patch five for baldur's gate three so
the way this is working this is what we
call the active roll interface
and so we changed a little bit how the
dice rolls are working in the game
from now on as you have to do a dice
roll during a dialogue or if you're
disarming a trap or if you're trying to
open a chest
you are going to be able to actually
cast your spells
during the roll so for instance uh we
could ask charlotte to do a little
guidance spell
is that a doable thing charlotte of
course all right
all right go for it
okay and so that should trigger uh that
should trigger get adding guidance to it
before we roll can we do that please
yes there we go get the guidance on top
of it and roll that dice
and then let's cross our fingers that
that's gonna work tear will help us
and that's a critical fail oh well
good for you
all right now i see that you were an
inspired man my friend oh of course i am
can you tell me
uh like uh because we have another new
feature that was added
to uh patch f5 and that is actually
a it's a pretty big feature it's called
background so
from now on if you pick a background
you're gonna discover there's a whole
bunch of little quests in the game that
are going to earn you inspiration points
if you play to your background so that
means what is your background stan
obviously i'm a shortened fan all right
and how did you become a charlatan
well by picking locks it's what i do all
right
well all right so uh well since you
earned i'm pretty sure that you earned
that inspiration point somehow
so i suggest we use that inspiration
point and try that role again to see if
you can actually manage to get in there
so background goals obviously a big
thing and we added over 130 of these
little background goals in the game for
you to discover
and here we're going to see the results
of that and that guidance spell is still
active and that means
well don't stain you can open the chest
it's open sven all right careful careful
there's oh there's so much loot no much
loot in here all right tell us what you
find
all right i see
what a drawing what's this that's an egg
give it to me i'm the leader now
it's a picture of an upside down egg an
egg
i'll put it in my inventory all right
you can bag that that sounds that sounds
like a good idea to me
all right an egg there's lots of other
stuff in here what's that
salami
is
anything interesting in the chest guys
there's a a a card with a horse you
can't eat that
a horse and an egg okay what else cheese
is that's for the elf
there we go part of the vegetarians wait
a minute all right this looks important
oh what does it say what is it i don't
know
i'm a fighter
scroll of speak with that i believe
speak with that scroll wow that's gonna
be useful because
when you speak with that scroll what can
we do with it speak with the dead
oh really oh wow i think so i don't know
all right let's
let's keep that with us okay i'm putting
it in my inventory all right
okay anything else more cheese a lot
more cheese or cheese
yes what is this like the supermarket
do you want to take this you can't just
keep it okay
all right i mean your inventory is
limited by weight i am i i would like to
remind you
all right so this is useless i mean we
didn't we just got
food all right you find anything else
inside there
okay somebody's asking you to hey
they're asking if you can use the scroll
to speak with the salami
no then we don't have i think it's hold
on to it
isn't this limited to speaking with that
people that you that still actually have
a mouth
very good david very good i can see how
does a fighter know these things
actually i don't know i'm surrounded by
very wise people
exactly all right chad where shall we go
now you need to tell me where we're
going to take this party here
they want you to look at the armor the
armor the
arm there's more stuff here yeah they
want you to look at the army armor
okay i'm sure that's completely safe
yeah for sure i mean i can uh
uh okay i'm i'm looking at the armor all
right
do you want me what do you want okay
okay touch it there's uh
touch it yeah touch it wait wait wait
wait
david yes it was safe yes take the
salami and use it as a weapon
oh but i have a sword with me actually
but okay i'll just get you i'll get the
salad
use it as a weapon and poke the armor
with the salami
poke the poke the armor yeah
salami weapon what's your salami skills
okay what's with the hand is it moving
yeah okay all right
okay that looks good anything else yeah
all right so party they want you to look
for fake walls can you look at fake
walls
okay all right listen to the sound of
the water running through them
no this looks like very very sturdy
stuff actually
uh this is a real castle yeah okay i
think this used to be a fake wall
and then they uh there's a huge map in
the middle of the room
uh they would like you to take the sword
you try taking the sword
i'm
all right all right party all right all
right chat chat
yeah well are you out of breath already
you wanted to have like a an older man
as your party leader yeah that was maybe
i should have taken far online
20 years ago my strength was like 18
plus all right so chad told me to
send you to the map there's a map you
mentioned go
and have a check at the map please well
i was looking at the map and i can uh
verify that there's no
false walls anywhere around this room
all right what do you see let me see
what you see oh wait
okay all right so that looks interesting
let me see all right
chad's not very impressed by your
fighting skills they want you to
look at the skull cards skull card
there's a skull card there
yeah right here they want you to grab it
they want you to grab
it and put it in your in my inventory i
think so yes
yeah and also they would like you to
have a look at the book
which one uh oliver twist oh that
doesn't sound like it's gonna
take us very far oh it's a secret book
it's got a secret thing on the inside
uh it's an open book yeah it's so secret
there's nothing in there
nothing nothing everyone forgot about it
all right okay
all right so let's see uh
yeah somebody they would suggest that
you should romance the armor
anybody want to romance the armor
romance the romance the armor
no no not happening i'm not very
charismatic no golden
world not happening not getting it all
right okay this works
the armor is a very popular thing right
now there's a
very yeah okay so while you're romancing
the armor can we continue looking if we
find us anything of interest here on
this table
[Laughter]
somebody mentioned the bloody handprint
there's a bloody handprint also on the
desk
on the desk on the desk on the desk yeah
i mentioned this ah there yeah
the druid has found it it does look like
it doesn't
it's not very similar is that very
similar no but
it does have a marking on it there's
some opening here yeah there's it put
your finger in nick are you already
doing it
that's that's not very clever you know
all right there's a tag on the horse
they say there's a tag on the horse
have a look at the tag on the horse what
does it say the tag on the horse says
in the prime of life in the prime
of life
no put the horse in the wood thing put
the horse in the
in this thing yeah it's not gonna it it
doesn't
it doesn't fit no it doesn't fit all
right
no no it doesn't fit yeah all right so
let's put the salami in the
hole put the salami in the hole
uh wait i can't find my my inventory is
already cluttered
okay here's the salt oh that's a close
fit yeah no
nothing happens no all right there's a
couple of round things
here uh where why where are you well
we haven't i know i was looking at the
titles of these books when i noticed
these cups for example
a cup you say let's see okay let's have
a look at the covers
yeah anything in the cupboard because
that's why it's called a cupboard i
guess because it has cups
and boards uh try moving a book check
the books if there's any movable books
in there
can you guys try moving books to see if
anything opens
yeah move the books no no no secret
stuff
all right no no no no foot
i'll save that for later no not a book
drink the cup
then there's no cup there's nothing in
the cups yeah okay
anything of interesting anything else
there oh i see somebody's talk about a
mannequin do you see a mannequin
a mannequin yeah who busy
yeah this little puppet yeah yeah oh
it has a red mark on it oh
that's more stuff on the base and more
what's on the base
uh tc i don't know what that's all right
okay taking care
probably all right so what else do you
see
uh i'll i'll just put this thing in my
inventory again i want you to plug it in
the hole
plug it in the hole in the hole
let's plug the dolly in the hole that is
very scary language
yeah that sounds like a good thing all
right so let's do that it's not going to
fit either i mean
oh my god wait a minute what happened it
completely fits oh oh
i swear the harness just moved no the
sword was up and it's down
if you look at the harness we can't see
the harness i'm going to put away my
salami
give the salami to to stain so that he
can protect you then can you hold my
stomach
to the vampire really yeah at least
we're protected now all right
so you too nick are you ready to cast a
spell
always ready all right okay just check
that armor keep your eyes on that armor
uh and let's uh yeah
what else do you want me to do chat take
the statue they said
move the doll move the doll that's a
good idea charlotte you remove the doll
yeah
maybe not the salami maybe
they would like they would like to try
to make the armored dance ymca actually
they want all of you to dance
are you ready yeah three two
what is this dance
wow the harness was the best one
actually yeah he did that very well but
we're not
getting making any proof and we are here
to find a scrying exploring orb
express we're having too much fun yes
okay so make him scratch his head
no i can't what else is there i mean all
right so wait what
and we need we need to make progress
have has anyone noticed that tiny
cupboard there there's a three card
somebody said three cards three cards
i didn't see it
which three card chad i don't understand
it which three card
three card you see three guard yeah on
the shelf there's a three card
oh there's three cards just look like a
chair all right it does look like a tree
i always thought it was something else
but that that that looks
yeah oh yeah all right all right all
right
talk to the skull can somebody do a
hamlet here oh
all right alas poor yorick
i knew him well et cetera et cetera
et cetera in the mind to suffer the
slings
oh there's a label all
things oh that doesn't sound good yeah
that's uh that's pretty difficult
pretend you never saw it yeah okay and
also it doesn't someone might come for
it
yeah that is actually really good all
right so
we got have a bad feeling about this i
think you're doing great you're still
not dead
so this is like this is the record all
right this is so hold on hold on
they want you to kiss the skull kiss the
skull here's the skull
kiss the skull yes maybe use me but wait
do you want to kiss something that says
the end of all things yeah why not i'm a
fighter give it give it to the give it
to stain he's a rogue he's a rogue
he's oh that makes sense he's like a
vampire he's probably used to this
my fur lady who says it was a lady i say
it's
lady okay all right
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right let's just put that camera can
we yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna do this 80s
camera move where they go like
i'll put this in my inventory i'll keep
it for later okay
why do we keep on bringing along this
guy
chad talked to rome party here i think
all right
they want you to but we can't speak with
that because we don't have any debts i
mean we need a mouth
and like it's called can you speak with
a skull i don't think you can speak with
a scroll no
you know it's disembodied it is a tongue
there is no life in the skull
all right what is that what's in front
of you there uh i think there used to be
a pool table here or something
somebody's mentioning a whale cart do
you see a well cart
what a whale cart oh yeah there's a huge
wheel on this car
or at that pole wait a minute that looks
like
slots yes i i'm seeing the word slots
put all the cards in the slots they say
uh you think we have enough cards to
fill five slots what do you have in your
inventory
let's put them in there let me see what
i have in my inventory all right
uh let's see the upside uh down egg
uh there's the skull yeah
and i also have a tree
and i have the horsey you have all of it
all right okay now
i think whoa whoa wait wait what the
heck
the statue is moving i i put in the
cards and then the
the armor just started moving all right
chat is having discussions about
in which order you should put it so
we're gonna put it up
no don't push it okay all right i'm
seeing a
strong preference for option
c option c yeah that's kind of
option c all right chad you need to use
the feature
choose the feature to vote chat
which one yeah it looks like c is going
to win
so clearly they think that an egg and a
fish and a horse
and something that looks like a tree and
a skull is a really good idea
all right okay all right well let's do
that okay yeah yeah tell me what to do
well wait i need to have an official
result first i'm waiting for the
official jury thing guy the var to tell
me that it's unforeseen
but you can't trust the farc all right
so first put
the um what's his name
uh no yeah
okay yeah yeah just put put
the egg the egg actually what would you
do
you don't want to know no all right okay
all right put the egg put the egg
yeah are you sure chat yeah all right so
put the
uh put the skull the skull
because it's shaped like an egg yeah i
get this put the horse
the horsey uh put the deadpool
did that you think this is a that ball
it was a whale just there was a whale a
second ago
yeah and uh what whatever you have left
this is a black metal logo
yeah yeah yeah hey david yeah yeah
anyway no just thinking of you well
that's better than thinking a photo
all right all right oh yeah that's true
actually okay so i i put down stuff
again yeah
yeah the the armor is still in an
attacking position
all right just push that button push
that button push it
just pushing it but that put that push
it
[Music]
i might have misunderstood what you guys
were telling me
uh well um yeah well anyway i thought
it was time for firing for that we
needed a firing in there so let me have
a look here
i know i know i know i know i should
have done that that was wrong
it was wrong i'm not gonna do it again
i'm gonna be i pretend
i promise that i'm not gonna do this
again anyway this was
david all right can you see him all
right it's david
all right may we remember him right uh
like
obviously he should have figured this
out for himself so i don't i didn't
think he really needed all that guidance
so david goodbye david all right and we
continue
i have a big stack of these so but i'm
not gonna do that again
i'm just gonna i'm sorry i'm really
chat uh yeah i forgot i i can actually
reload but i forgot to quicksave so
not gonna be able to reload david uh
just
yet uh we are
[Laughter]
we're gonna uh we're gonna go back we
still have three adventures and we will
have opportunities for getting the extra
adventures coming and i just wanted to
yes well i mean i thought well i mean he
was old
and all that all right all right
[Music]
all right nick yes nick here
we might have misplaced one of the cards
we should probably put
the that was not a great start i think
i'm gonna say
chat yeah i i don't let me down this
time yeah i missed click miss
it happens uh put the skull instead of
the
wait a minute now i need to remember how
it actually works all right put the egg
then the tadpole the whale the big whale
is actually a tadpole
it's like a cycle of life thing and then
you need to put the horses right and
then you need to swap
around the tree and the skull yeah i
like that tree
yeah this looks like the same mix all
right i'm uh
yes okay okay all right sure i think i
think that
that that looks really good to me and
you want to push that button
do i want to push that button i think
you should push the button are you sure
all right look armor boy
yeah no killing all right can you stand
that
all right no killing all right all right
all right
there's a button here all right all
right all right go for it push it
oh my god it's a shrine of course
of course the druid needed to open the
shrine they did absolutely dude it's
full of greenery this is beautiful son
amazing is this this crying orb oh wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait i
i i don't know what's gonna happen if
you touch it chad should he touch it or
not
is it the crying crystal maybe maybe
that's why we're here it doesn't look
like an ornament no one has to die i
just need to take it and we're going to
go right
[Music]
i'll check with chat chat i'm letting
you i'm letting you
does anybody ever detect magic uh spell
handy
nature check arcane check check anything
check something it's pretty no
it's pretty somebody sends it
well it's overloading that must be the
thing what do you think do you have an
arcana check right here
in your head nick no only nature checks
i'm sorry
they expect more you know yeah
okay so somebody just said no detect
just touch all right just go for it
all right there's nothing
i actually should have probably touched
it with the salami indeed that was a
really
really good oh no all right okay well he
was worthless
um all right chad i'm sorry um now
we're gonna do better at this so we're
actually
uh where is he let me see
where is he oh man of course there's
always the last one right
so nick worthless
okay we continue all right so
uh i guess that we're going to uh have
to figure it out now it's all going to
be up to you you clearly saw what my
skills are they're not very good at this
uh so we're gonna i stain i think it
this is going to be your moment
for prime time i mean you're dead
already technically speaking so like you
can't really
die so we should be good so i um
staying can you hear me here he's fine
yeah all right
well i think this is a uh i'm not
rigging anything i'm not doing anything
like i'm being accused of rigging this
game stain so
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna say
literally what chat tells you
all right and then it's up to you okay
all right
and yeah come on chat
can you see us sven i can see you all
right oh my god
we lost two men already sven we have to
be more careful i'm i'm going to
i'm refusing to quicksave we're doing
this hardcore maybe i'll click save if
you guys manage to get out of this room
all right after somebody wants you to
touch the body
touch the body yeah burn the body nick
or you mean the first turn the body no
this was my friend i'm not burning him
all right well you can touch him does
anybody have a stroll of revivify
no we have no scroll of revival all
right use the mannequin
ah that's that that sounds like a good
idea all right
touching it that man mannequin yeah
mannequin
yeah this is uh some people predict
you're never going to get
out of this room all right now what do
you want me to do with the mannequin
i'm afraid they're going to say that
they want you to kiss the mannequin it's
the mannequin
no i don't i well they didn't actually
say it yet
okay they didn't they want you to see
this jealous fan
now they want you to use the mannequin i
don't want to make the skull jealous
you don't want to make skulls all right
so touch wait hold on a minute
uh what what chad you're going too fast
i'm trying to understand so i'm just
going to pick them uh walk to the
crystal i read
walk to the crystal walk to the crystal
i'm gonna try so
uh right leg up yeah make man again
touch the
oh maybe if i do right left
all right oh so we go uh
right yeah all right left oh my god
right
left right left right
left stop oh all right i want you to
turn
and make the the mannequin bend over at
least five times
so turn and now do
five bows yes one two
three four five all right
and then they want you two
yes the right leg also bend and reach
all right with two hands all right
all right oh the sword is in the way oh
well maybe we should decide oh wait
this brings me actually to one of the
features that we have in patch five
we actually have a disarm feature in
patch five so now from now on you will
be able to disarm
enemies and it's actually pretty cool
because they will pick up weapons that
they find and they will
they can throw in matthew uh but
disarming is now
also a feature that is available to you
so can we disarm
the um
right statue yeah make him drop it all
right which dominican you mean yeah
no no just yes i think do you want the
cleric to do it or the rogue
uh i don't know chats cleric of rogue
all right
[Music]
look at that look at those skills that
actually worked all right well you are
you're okay i'm going back to work
i'll put it in my inventory i might sell
it later all right
okay go try reach the arms forward
yeah go a bit further with the feet
very good no more more
more more duck duck stuck
duck this is exciting and i reach
oh my god he's holding it is he dying no
no no no it's working it's working it's
working all right
and now what and now what go back there
you go go back oh god it's moving
it's moving
well what's happening now
okay wow look at that
oh oh it's taking off it's taking off
you got a copper going up in the air is
that a
is that a hole i see all right
chad what shall we do shall we enter the
hole or are we just going to sit around
here and have some salami
no the
chat is saying secret passage secret
passage there we go they want you to
enter the hole
all right all right let's do it all
right don't forget to salaam it
i'll come right behind you okay enter
the hole
enter the hole and we got a loading
[Music]
screen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we are back in our next
section of our great adventure our
adventures are taking a well-deserved
break
as they are recovering from their
efforts and they are mourning the dead
of course
so uh as we are here in camp this is
actually a really good moment to talk
about some of the other features that
are coming in your direction of patch
five
first of all you notice that this camp
is set in a crypt and not
in a forest and that is because with
patch five from now on wherever you're
gonna go to sleep
the camp setting is going to match the
setting of
where you went to sleep that's a big
thing because we had to make sure that
all the cinematics were going to work
with if you went to sleep in the
underdark
you have to be in the underdark if you
went to sleep in the crypt you have to
be in a cryptif in the cave in a cave in
the forest well actually in a forest
so that's been done now so it's
something you've been asking for for
quite some time
uh but it took us a lot of effort but it
is finally in
and that's not the only thing that's
happening you noticed our party
also took a lot of salami and some
cheese with them well that is because we
have started differentiating short rests
from
long rest more than they were expected
so
here you see on our screen that we are
actually using
camp supplies before we have to go to
sleep and that means that if you take
the camp supplies oh sorry let me put it
this way
if you eat sufficiently at camp then
you're going to have the benefits of a
full rest
however if you don't have enough food
with you you will still be able to rest
but you will get what we call a
shallow rest or a partial rest and that
essentially means that you're not going
to get all of your spouses and not all
of your hp
restored when you go to sleep so
managing your supplies is going to
become important that long rest has
become a more of a
strategic critical resource for you to
manage the guys that have uh um let's
say bony when they do short rest they're
obviously going to get the benefits
from that experimental feature putting
it in an early access to see
if you like it yes or no certainly it
has made finding food
much more important in the game and
it actually it works i mean i know my
opinion it works
pretty well all right so uh
we need some replacements we lost david
may he rest in peace
we lost nick may he rest in peace but we
still
have some fantastic adventures sitting
in our party we have inner
or warlock uh we have kelly or wizard
and then of course we have farron the
ranger
who are you going to pick chat it's up
to you unity pick
who is going to be uh in our party now
so we get to pick
two characters uh that are going to
replace the two dead
characters all right so we're gonna
listen to
what you have to say uh
as the party continues to enjoy
their well-deserved rest
all right so looking like the warlock
and the wizard are going to win
so inner is a uh
it is very pleased by that and kelly uh
kelly looking well looking like kelly uh
always very serene being a wizard and a
sage
uh so it means that you're keeping
wizard and warlock you're keeping your
ranger for last
which might be a clever idea because you
might actually need somebody that can
stay
distant from everything else all right
so warlock
and wizard is kelly and in it are
joining the party together with staying
and charlotte so we have a rogue a
cleric
a um wizard and a warlock continue our
adventure into the
dungeons of gustav von drachenfell it's
also the right moment to tell
lars that he should go to sleep because
this is a time when everybody goes to
sleep so party please go to sleep
tomorrow we have a very very big day
ahead of us we're going to continue our
adventure
in the castle so it's the moment to rest
just saying chat
or load times are very long but this is
like a real-life ssd so considering that
it's a pretty
fast loading times all right let's go to
sleep party
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so as our party is dreaming and snoring
and
uh yeah i don't know what they are doing
in their sleep uh
we are going to have a small q a so you
can just drop your questions in the chat
if i can read them fast enough i will
try
to answer them and then as we wait for
our party to move to their
next room uh so i'll what
uh what i'm trying to i'm seeing seduce
salami
these questions are going too fast i see
that you're waiting for new classes i've
seen a lot of speculation on what the
next new class is going to be
i can promise you new classes are coming
this is a patch which has dominantly
focused on features
it also allowed us to do a whole bunch
of work in the background it's obviously
uh not everything that is chipping is
everything that we're working on when it
comes to an update we're also trying to
fill
or create the full game so there is
going to be a very
content heavy patch after this one
coming this is more of a feature patch
but they're important features because
we needed to get them out there
we need you to test them and so uh in
the next one you're going to get
uh what your hearts are craving for in
terms of content i think
all right so let's see um
oh my god it's going really fast it's
very hard to uh
all right what about new races new races
uh
we are going to be very stingy on those
uh we do want to keep
a whole bunch of content for when the
actual game is going to release so that
when it releases it feels like
a big celebration of a whole bunch of
new content
so we still have a whole bunch of things
planned for early access
what's going to be in there i'm afraid
i'm going to give you the political
answer and not
answering uh so that is that how that
works
what else do we see plus one salami dlc
weapons when
uh really good question actually i
probably should talk to wizards of coast
about that
um i'm seeing that's a race question
uh yeah
uh uh elaborate on background goals so
uh yeah so for all of the backgrounds
that are in early access
uh you are going to discover as you're
playing and you play to your background
that you're going to get a uh you're
going to get rewarded for it
and it will be inspiration points which
have now a cap actually the cap is set
at four
and so if you go over that gap you're
going to get experience points for
hitting those background goals you're
going to have a nice new ui where you
can
see all the background goals that you've
achieved whenever user inspiration
points you can earn new ones
we're not going to tell you where they
are there's about 130 that were placed
in early access right now they're tied
to very specific things well i'll give
you one example so for instance if you
are
going to be an acolyte and you happen to
find a
book of the dead gods then that's going
to be important for you as an acolyte
and that's going to get you an
inspiration point
uh if you do the right things over there
as an acolyte
uh continuing um i saw a question about
loot uh so yeah so there's a there's a
lot of work happening
actually on uh making uh handcrafted
uh magic weapons they take some time
because we're trying to make them very
unique
but you will see a trickle of them
there's actually a few new ones coming
in in this patch
you will see them more and more of them
coming in to the game
i see a lot of level five questions uh
the jury is still out on that of whether
or not we're gonna put level five in act
one and so if you keep on asking hard
enough maybe one day that is going to
happen uh i am seeing a lot of
multi-class questions multi-classing is
something that we've confirmed in the
past so i can reconfirm it for you
most likely that's going to be late
during the early access campaign
uh because we probably want to have all
of the classes in first but maybe we're
going to change our minds on this you
know who knows
seeing a lot of sanitary questions i'm
not going to say anything about that
uh reactions is certainly something that
we're going to be extending
uh but that's not going to be in this
patch then
salami and companions uh
who is on the pig behind me that would
be raphael the devil
all right i hear that our party is uh
has
awoken from their slumber and so we are
going to jump back
to uh the adventuring party that is
trying to enter
the castle of gustav von drachenfell
all right who's that
ah it's a ropes me all right okay let's
see
it's kind of a chapel guy be careful we
have to be careful because there's
there's a dead body right there that guy
that guy all right so there might be
a round be careful where he's all right
can you stan can you look at
beneath you at your feet i can't see
what's there what's that
look at all kinds of symbols and
there are some symbols on the wall
symbols on the wall yeah
all right somebody wants you to eat the
dead guy he's a dead guy
i just ate at camp do not sorry sorry oh
god
is your is your sixth sense telling you
something he was always gonna step
stepping on one of those clearly magic
chad chat wants to speak with that
they want you to speak with that speak
with the dead
speak slowly and clearly
we'll try this yeah okay all right so
what does it say
enochte
how did you die lightning
everywhere who are you
daniel swiftfoot
rogue why were you here
stealing needed gold
who told you about this place
you have to be careful because we have
limited amount of questions that we can
ask you to speak with that spell
i was slightly distracted i wasn't
watching this these are your last
questions right
now so we should ask chad to ask which
question is your last question
so we're going to let them vote what is
going to be the final question here
let's see what they have to say seeing a
whole bunch of letters appear on the
screen
all right getting a lot of b's and c's
looks like c ah really chat
like really c all right
okay what are the correct symbols we're
going to ask stan the question
what are the correct symbols what are
the correct symbols
not the one i'm on
all right you hear that party that
wasn't very
that wasn't very helpful no not the one
year not the one he's on
right we could have figured it out
ourselves if we step on the wrong symbol
i guess we somehow
die i i i think
yeah so hey wait can you just uh oh stop
i wanna before you die
by trying this thing out okay i i
there's two things i would like you to
do okay
all right can you jump over it jump over
it yeah just jump over it
jump over it yay so why do i
do this because i wanted to pitch one of
the patch five
features which is the ability to jump
now without disengage
or disengage without jumping rather
something that community has been asking
for a long time that we split the jump
and disengage so we did
uh we actually removed uh the jump and
this guy the bundling of the jump and
disengage and so now
you can do that and actually we also put
a shortcut in for jumping so it's a
little bit easier i'm not going to say
that it's perfect yet but it's going to
be a lot easier for you
all right i was pitching patch 5 stain
sorry sorry
okay what do we what what do we have
there it's
is that the weight point i think it's a
waypoint it's not activating anything
an unactivated waypoint all right
interesting all right so they
ah all right say it again
okay all right like the first one has a
green light
so there must be a way of activating it
maybe if we can get like we need green
light
puzzles
don't step don't step all right say
the suggestion from chad is that you
actually uh throw salamis
do you bring the salamis right now i
know you ate them all they ate all the
salamis chat
this seems to be solved this is solved
yes
what would it be like so we have three
weapons here
like a sword or a skimmer an axe
i don't know about weapons i only read
books
you're going to have to you're the
weapons expert okay
so well if i would have to sneak up to
someone
yes i would use a melee weapon and it
looks like this is a ranged weapon
yeah this is just a shield and this is a
melee weapon you want to go stand on a
melee weapon to backstab someone careful
careful
i'm gonna be careful maybe maybe
it's well i don't know just stand on it
see if it works like
well oh no all right
all right that was the left one
i guess this one must be the left one as
well right that makes perfectly
sensitive
[Music]
oh i forgot to press f5 i know i did we
had an autosave
did we have an autosave oh
somebody died god i don't want him to
die
i don't want him to die all right chad
me i'm standing here
i actually had a save game of that
so what are we gonna do what are we
gonna do
are we gonna bring him back are we gonna
bring him back
this incompetent drook who just stepped
on his own
it's up to you chad oh you can't see him
there he is look at him he's cute though
uh so reload or not reload all right all
right all right
all right we're gonna bring him back all
right we want the rogue back we are
reloading can we have a
proper loading screen or we'll just
reload them
reload them reload them right and then
tell them not to do that anymore
can we reload them is stained reloadable
the dumb broke henceforth known as the
dumbest of rogue we actually didn't
uh well we did all right reload turret
is very popular so
people want him to reload yeah safe's
coming yes well safe coming is a very
important i mean i've been safe coming
my entire player career
ever since i played my first games the
moment i had a save
i used it you don't want to know how i
played the original basket in the very
very very beginning i was just
safe coming continuously all right
you need to trust me okay you need to
trust me
it's wrong stain whatever you're
thinking okay
go stand on the middle thing next to the
dead guy
the middle thing next are you sure sven
i am 100 sure i know
this is
just do it just do it sure yes
and and and what's happening wow oh oh
yeah you're so clever sven yeah i know
thank you
uh can you all right it's um i don't
know i'm a very
yes yes that must be it i'll let you
just figure this all out they're green
and these aren't
and we have one so if we solve these two
puzzles then we're out of here yeah
before we get get excited before you get
excited
i am i'm gonna ask chad what they want
you to do don't do anything on your own
okay
can we hold the urges back all right
okay yes we should
read about this first research is always
best all right okay
all right so uh we are actually
chat chat i mean like i'm disappointed
in you because you're all talking to
speak okay they want you to
speak with that first they want me to
speak with the corpse yeah that's what i
would have done
yes well you can just speak with the
debts i can yes you can speak with the
debt could think
you're walking where you're walking am
yeah
i can stand in the middle right you
can't stand in the middle all right
all right and then you speak with the
dead okay
all right all right somebody in it yes
yes
we talked a lot about background goals
and i just saw somebody say a thing
about
sing a song i remember your background
what's your background again
oh my god sven why do you bring this up
now yes please i was an entertainer but
you know that i failed
i can't sing all right i know this all
right sing as a tune in
what do i have to sing i don't know like
all right chad what does she what do you
want her to say
down down by the river
that yeah and chad is saying like they
they like in the elephant world
they are clapping they're clapping uh
wonderful can you do wonder wall just to
show that this is life
wonderful yeah and after all
[Laughter]
i wonder this is this is why i'm not an
entertainer this is why i am here right
now
like risking my life to get a stupid
crying arm
don't say chad i am very disappointed in
you there's a dead body what is the very
first thing you do when you find a dead
body in baldur's gate
is there something you cannot suck at
the stain that's not gonna happen
what is it yes loot it's looted exactly
chat now finally you're doing it
all right just no no anything it's
no no nothing no not even like no
an issue maybe an issue all right yeah
check the shoe
okay take your shirt i really feel like
we should be focusing on the
waypoint but don't you want extra shoes
you don't know what these shoes do
like maybe can you throw i had great
success in the past with throwing shoes
[Laughter]
okay um no no no no
i can throw it though i am surrounded by
amateurs
watch out nothing happened all right
well that's good well we established
that shoes do not trigger the traps this
is very good
very good i'm very clearly magic clearly
magic
so what do we do now sven uh i don't
know chad what are we gonna do
and then like we're gonna leave the body
alone yeah
all right like maybe we should have a
look at the
uh yeah where should these are not
yeah and the next one and this one so we
have like two ducks here
it's a swan it's clearly a swan it's
ancient that we have
everybody clearly some kind of bridge
oh yeah then here we have like a wine
glass
yeah a wine glass
and i think this is like this is what
happens when you make a vampire the
leader
that is clearly that is clear
all right all right i think chad is
fairly committed they don't want you to
mess up i'm just going to press that f5
button again
just in case you you screw it up or
somebody gets really excited
so yes i think that is a very good
picnic table there stan
i think you're all right so
chad have you made up your mind what are
we gonna do
which one are we gonna hit f5 has been
pressed don't worry about it team
we've i've got you covered f5 is sorted
out
uh so where
okay chad has chad decided
yes all right press the okay the the one
on the right
the one on the right that one yeah
whatever it is you didn't fail us before
sven so i'm gonna trust you on this yeah
[ __ ] totally wow
that's the last one ah look at that all
the green lights doesn't that make us
happy
uh this sounds really good okay i
believe we need to
solve one more puzzle all right one all
right okay
hey you know what chad this is
completely up to you i'm not going to
say anything
like uh there are little points wait
what is this
gonna be careful not to step on these
things all right okay but there's like
there's nothing in them can i take the
shoes away or something
don't touch it i wouldn't all right
okay so there's nothing in them i don't
know what to do here
hold on how many how many of you are
there how many of you are there
there's now four of us four of
you all right so that means that there's
only two options okay all right
uh chad who shall we ask to stand on the
right
square just on the right square anybody
any favorite person that you want to
move on the right square
just by elimination we can do this like
i mean like we're certainly going to get
there right
so are we going to like
the right square the warlock i see
i see the word rogue pop-up stan can you
can you just go under on the right
square
like by elimination by elimination we
will just do this all right
all right so i got you covered buddy
don't worry about it all right
you're not gonna film it this time all
right well i'm not gonna stay safe
all right are you all right but yeah it
goes nothing span all right
no that wasn't the one that was the one
all right excellent
excellent we've established this now we
know there's only two left
so uh obviously i am fairly upset by the
accusations of safe's coming so i'm not
gonna save scum
so chad you're gonna decide whether it's
gonna be the left one or the middle one
i'm not really sure if
the the direction has set up a vote for
this but it's gonna be up to you so you
better start thinking i'll let you look
at that picture again
if it's the left or the middle one and
then we're just gonna see what's gonna
happen
left or middle chat left or middle think
very hard
roll for anything that you can think of
but you're gonna have to
pick it up um are you
ah are we getting a vote for this all
right and so everybody saying the left
one
looks like it um was that a vote
all right and so left or middle
interesting
i don't know which one i would just send
both of i should have sent both of them
actually i mean like we have four left i
mean like there's a hold on which one
was this
stain all right all right so here he
goes
you stain say goodbye favorite rogue
very cool rogue he did very well
actually i mean he wasn't totally
incompetent so
i mean but anyway he's dead all right
next
um i wonder who we're gonna get are we
gonna get any replacement
all right maybe we should get uh
who's gonna be our leader now our cleric
i guess our cleric okay we're gonna put
a cleric as the leader
are we getting reinforcements or are we
yeah i think it's time for a ranger to
come into action right so
uh if anything we can just put him on
the whatever
yeah i'm gonna bring in and i'm not
going in there i know what's gonna
happen i think they're all gonna die all
right
okay so left as what chat has voted for
with a large majority apparently
all right i wonder what made them think
left is the right answer
probably they thought that stain was
onto something in the beginning when
they set left
so let's have a look let's bring in
farang
and then uh see what happens uh as we
continue our adventure into the
dungeons of count drachenfel
the famous gustavon dragonfell with his
sharp fangs
very bad temper but sometimes
all right sometimes adorable looks
all right okay
all right oh he's dead hello who is this
oh this is
yes hi we we oh my god ferran you came
running
i'm here i'm ready for this baby okay
thank you so much
for
the group hive mind is never wrong they
want you to go
on the left charlotte on on the one we
threw shoes out
before before you do that yeah before
you do that before you do that charlotte
yeah what's your background of course an
acolyte
an acolyte how did you become a cleric
it was such a hard training but it's the
sounds of the forest that guided me
sounds of the force that guided you
what does that mean ah only elves
understand that language
okay all right you don't want to tell me
your sob story of how you became an
acolyte
oh fine so we were hiding with my three
sisters under the table and it was
thunder and lightning and we were very
scared
and all of a sudden a fireball hit the
window and it got
over and around the table and it didn't
hit us
and i mean that must have been something
else and i believe it's been a god
and that's when i started believing in
tyr all right well you know what put a
prayer to your god as you go
stand on the left the left one charlotte
pray to your god maybe you should do the
prayer first okay there's a high chance
we're not gonna hear the prayer
afterwards
[Music]
[Laughter]
go for it charlotte okay ready guys one
two just do it
why don't we do a little dance for for
thanking the gods of charlotte
which god was that charlotte tier all
right well back there
oh my god yeah and take that waypoint
right well done chad that was actually
impressive i thought you were gonna fail
on this one
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
all right chad you're doing great we are
going to be
entering the finale of our little rpg
and if you manage to succeed
in the grand finale we're going to
release that uh update video for you in
which we're going to be talking about
all of the features
uh in patch 5. but before we do that
we have time for a little bit of q a as
the gods of the loading screens
are getting our party ready and set up
for their final challenge of the evening
so let's see what's coming in there um
all right so no new classes today yet no
like not happening lots of um the
romance is to have to
be patient yeah there's romance is
coming but romans has to be patient
uh stain's dead yeah so nothing to be
done about it
um all right so multi-classing i already
talked about
patch five is coming on july 13th that's
next tuesday if it all goes well i
crossed my my fingers
uh there is actually a little bit of new
content and patch five you're gonna
discover
well actually there's quite a lot of
permutations that were added and new
choices
oh yes and how can i well well i could
mention it now too no i'm
am i going to mention it now maybe uh
uh i'm trying to figure out if we're
actually going to show you no we're not
we're we're yeah no uh yes so big thing
uh as you are going to be in uh
the tutorial uh there was something that
you have been uh oh
you never want you know what i'll let it
i'll leave it for the update i'm not
gonna just not gonna say it
uh all right so let's see what else we
have uh
as a question uh the way the inventory
is managed is a little bit
uh hard we know this we're working on
this it's not gonna be for this patch
but we are working
on a revamp of how that entire system
works so that's coming in your direction
it'll take some time
but it is coming um what else do we have
um i got so many questions and so
it's a little time to interpret them uh
wait hold on uh are there
oh my god that's to go too fast i just
cannot read it anymore
so you have to slow down chest what else
can i tell you
um let's see okay is disengage
a bonus action no one is actually in
action in the
current version so we're going to try it
with that uh
so then what else do we have are there
ui chains there's a whole bunch of
smaller things that are part of this
patch
there's big ui overhauls on certain
things that are coming
but you need to have some patience local
multiplayer by which i think they mean
split screen
uh that is not in here yet uh
difficulty levels are that's something
that we'll put in very late i
i think um so that's going to come later
uh we're not adding a new origin
character just yet
uh actually an early access no that's
not the plan we really want to give you
a lot of content
when the game releases uh so we are
going to be trading over act one there's
a lot of stuff that's going to be
improving
and a lot of stuff is going to be
changing and improving on the cinematic
front
uh in the not so distant future and it's
actually going to look amazing
uh but not just yet um
how wait what is that
i know it's going to go a little bit too
fast so i can't read it anymore new
spells
are there new spells in uh patch five i
think some of them are are new in it it
wasn't the really main
focus for this one uh but there's
there's probably gonna be a bunch of uh
of new things that are in there for you
to discover uh
uh there is actually speaking of spells
that say uh
it's actually a big one also because a
lot of work went into it
and the vfx team has worked uh on
teaming
each of the classes so from now on if a
spell is specific to a class
you're going to see that there's a team
to it and that is going to allow
help with the recognizability of the
spells during
combat so it's a big thing speaking of
combat actually there's a shitload
of uh combat ai improvements in patch
five
uh it's starting to feel like it's
actually really uh
knowing uh the rules of the game and
it's starting to use them and
very interesting ways uh against you uh
while you're
playing uh yeah sorry about my language
there i uh
i apologize i'm not gonna do that again
uh what else do i have there
uh let's see a i'm seeing a lot of gm
mode questions
that is not on our schedule so i'm
afraid i will have to disappoint there
uh reactions we talked about we're going
to certainly improve
uh aspects of reactions in the future um
what else was that race questions class
questions
so um oh first time i see somebody else
for cobalt
uh that's kind of cool uh lots of
romance questions
uh max level questions we've covered all
of those already and new subclasses
class question more quests well you just
got over 130 background goals
so that counts as new quests although
they are not really officially quest but
they do give you a reward
all right we're gonna cut back i hear
that the party has
arrived so we're gonna head in that
direction and see
what the final challenge is going to be
that our party has to deal with
all right party can you hear me yeah i
can hear you sven this is the cleric
this is charlotte
all right charlotte how are you
this is not my normal surrounding uh
we're in some kind of dungeon kind of a
thing uh with a lot of
stuff all right okay chad you gotta you
have to guide
charlotte charlotte can you look around
see what you see that looks
i i really wouldn't go there that looks
is
yeah maybe you want to start on the
other side yeah this is interesting
there is yeah
what's that this place is really not
safe there is a box here
so shall we open the chest that is cool
but uh be careful aren't we should we
open this the chest
wait whoa whoa what just confirm it
don't open the chest don't open the
chest chat chat just saying a lot of
nose don't do
the chest don't okay all right all right
i don't know where chat was actually i
don't know if
they want you to have the chest or not
they're very confused it could be
there's a lot of spiders
can you poke it with something all right
should i poke it with a knife you could
you could definitely poke it with a
knife that sounds like a good idea
nothing's happening all right that that
was clearly a good idea
it's very very bloody though yeah maybe
just put it back
okay where you found it i mean like
maybe somebody's still using it
it it does look like something
was sacrificed here clearly imagine
people maybe they put somebody in the
chest maybe oh my god
should we look you think there's a dead
body in here can you smell
yes anything man yeah they all want you
to detect magic
and i guess it's always the same detect
magic deck magic deck magic oh well so
i'm finding somebody asked
that you drink the wine
we lost our vampire i am not drinking
that i am not drinking it all right and
there is somebody seeing spiders
yeah all right there is a lot of spiders
and
other stuff here all right as well
really careful with the water okay all
right
so there is a there is a move can you
look at on the other side see if you
find something
there's also this kind of an altar
looking thing like it's
incantations incantations yes i
recognize that it's runic
ah tell us what you see what is this
they're clearly
charms of some sort but to do what
that's the question
aren't these summoning runes yes
summoning rooms that sounds interesting
we must be able to summon
the orb you think you can summon the orb
the
orb
that we came here to find yeah oh that
there is
in the middle of the page like this yes
clearly
that sounds interesting i mean this
little round chap
that sounds like an orb right all right
well the okay let's see chad chad shall
we
get them to read something all right
are you kidding me we're going to read
this now yeah sure i don't know
i mean like what do you want to do can
you read the four phrases so that the
chat knows what's inside of the book
actually
okay so far wrong why don't you read the
first one
right a carnal creature pale
a feature his kiss would burn as hot
as fever all right nothing something
happened i really don't like the sound
of this guy
anything did anything happen no no no
check the room
check the room see if anything have the
chat wants you to check the room
right no no no no no shall we
shall we look in the chest chat look in
the chest
see if something something appeared oh
you wanna say you're
you're really confident wait wait wait
i'm listening to chat chat says no one
yes they say no one yes at the same time
oh my god what is it not so strange
there's a they want you to check the
barrel the barrel
i find that's a good idea i mean i would
like always check that
might be some cheese in there can you
try to check for traps firing
is that a thing you can do yeah yeah
there is there's nothing in here
there's nothing in the barrel no that's
a pity guys we have a bunch of final
dancers here
all these barrels are getting about this
giant like
mind flare kind of thing i don't know
what is it a mind player you say
i don't like the color in his eyes there
is some magic of foot here we haven't
figured it out but
i feel magically some magic a foot here
this did not just happen
out of the blue i know clearly not that
it must be somebody's blood
yes all right i can't i can't find any
traps then that doesn't look like the
place
no traffic magic is some of the most
powerful magic
yeah i i get that yes i see that
so um why don't we look in the chest
okay should we look in the chest yes
okay
carefree hey firing said no no no no
no it's empty
nothing anti-climactic
okay there has to be a trick to this
thing like it's fine it's not here
so i mean what is an empty chest doing
here what is this not here can we just
can you get into the chest oh you want
me to get in the chest
let me just try it out is that doable i
don't go
firing don't do it don't listen to
everything i don't want to i'm just
saying
just just saying check get in the chest
get in the chest a lot of people
saying get in the chest you know like
they're very very enthusiastic about you
getting in the chest
i want to get in the chest yeah get in
the chest don't worry this is pure all
right
how does it feel farron can you talk to
yeah just bend over a little bit more
i hope you guys go home and crawl in the
chest
oh god here we go all right here we go
all right
all right oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god all right
all right lock it okay
this is much quieter now
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right look away all right so look
look at the
at the thing yeah okay all right maybe
this this must do something i mean
it is a summoning charm i am positive i
studied them
all right maybe we should summon
something to join the firing in the
chest
maybe it's a summoning chest farang is
out of the chest he's out of the chest
yes did you summon him away
he is just too freaking fast for us
where is he
he's right here man
ah there is okay good i thought for a
second that he was going there
that was scary right okay let's see
um all right like so what are we gonna
do now
like i think that's all right
uh blood sacrifice i see maybe you
should read
the phrases i think blood
okay chad's saying blood sacrifice so
maybe you should read the phrases out
loud and then
not sacrifice something of course ah
there you go
all right all right read the book read
the book okay
okay all right there you go
what what what do you want us to
which one well we should read them out
okay oh there are okay so chad is seeing
what's inside of the book
and they can choose which phrase you
should read yeah
people can somebody check if it's really
firing
oh my god is it really fire yeah they're
not sure it's really firing
they might be a doppelganger it's me
it's me
it's me okay all right got in the chest
nothing happened tell me tell me
something that only i would know
i know how this goes i've seen this
movie are you sure sven
yeah tell me tell me what happened in
the tunnel
in paris when you were driving together
with octave coming back from a press
event are you serious
well no maybe not all details but all
right so basically the bottom line was
there was a snowstorm
after the press event of dragon
commander we're stuck on the highway
right i get out of the car to have a
little smoke
and the traffic clears up so oktav
starts driving away there i am on the
highway
knee deepest snow running after the car
nothing on me
my bag my passport everything was in the
car so i arrived like after running a
mile
after octave he breaks i opened the door
he looks at me
laughs out loud and he said i'm really
sorry i was wondering who the hell that
was running after the car
and he was on the phone with sven while
he was driving
and he was wondering who it was at the
back all right are you happy now
well i can confirm this is farang team
like no worries let's go back to our
mission
right so we have the book with the four
incantations all right we have some kind
of a
all right so chat has voted that you
start you do the secrets offer
information
truer than dark definition that one and
with this
just read the phrase charlotte okay read
the phrase
read it and then wait do i cut my hand
as well
right no i don't know chad do you want
her to cut her hand
she won't yeah they want you to bleed in
the ball
ew thanks chad that's very nice of you
well it's a sacrificial summon
okay all right so you're going to do
secrets over information
and you're going to bleed in the ball
all right so look at the hand we want to
see the handcuffs right
all right you guys you sure you want to
see this
well we want you to see yes of course i
mean like right it's a video game
i'm ready so all right okay secrets
offer information truer than dark
divination
some have bottoms without end sometimes
they
contain a friend
i heard for you oh that was good enough
i hope
take the chest check the chest yeah oh
my god my fingers first sven
dude i don't want to get like i don't
want to die i'm always complaining all
the time
like focus yes adventure adventuring
all right okay all right you want me to
open the chest now yes please
[Music]
and maybe uh uh i know how this goes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
uh
all right chad well done well done very
proud of you chad
like that was charlotte or cleric we're
out of clerics now
all right we're out of clerics all right
say wave goodbye to charlotte
this is charlotte uh in the end she
turned out to be a little bit
where are you oh like this yeah like
this in the end a little bit incompetent
all right oh she goes all right we only
have a few left we got our ranger
firearm
and we got inner or warlock i'm very
curious who is
going to be left over all right team
can you hear me theme
yes all right in it yes all right we're
gonna have to try that again in it
um it's farhang it's firing i'm sorry
i'm sorry farang
all right yeah all right so we have
confirmed that you're there we still
have you here
kelly and uh oh well that's that's
really great we have three more options
so
at least one of you is going to get it
right but we still have those crying
orbs so
uh-huh i i do not want to summon another
branch all right okay so are we going to
ask chat to vote
yeah all right so chad
we're gonna go by the frequency or the
the second vote
and your second vote was this little
round chap
is a misnomer fellow he's not curved
slender or yellow can you do that
yeah right i'll give it a try yeah
that's okay
it was nice knowing you farang been
around each other for a long time
all right so this little round chap
is a misnomered fellow and he's not
curved slender or yellow all right
all right all right damn it
we end up doing this yay all right
okay let's do this okay all right all
right stand back guys this is
this is it yeah yeah
what do we get what do you have what is
that
what is that it's a it's an orange what
does it say
why does it say banana
[Music]
it's an orange it says banana who which
name i think i think chad gets it banana
what kind of whimsical chest is this i
don't think this is a trying orb to be
honest
yeah i really don't think i i i'm not
sure that this is just fine or
all right it's good for supplies later
on
i'm not i'm not sure we should eat this
though hey
just take it with you you know you just
put it in maybe sorry can we focus
sorry i'm sorry so we should focus
totally
all right
all right the next one apparently was a
a carnal creature failure feature
his kiss would burn as hot as fever go
ahead try it up
are we gonna do this yes all right here
we go again i think you're gonna get to
kiss a carnal creature okay
this is always good a carnal creature
pale a feature this kiss would burn
that's the hardest fever i literally
that looks really painful it does
actually look painful
i really hope this carnal creature is
not another monster
[ __ ] all right maybe we should kill the
orange okay wait wait wait wait
i put the orange can i have a moment
here
yes this could be my last moment okay
okay a second time
here we go and
what the hell what's that hey i know
this guy
wasn't this one of stan's friends yes it
is indeed one of stayne's friends
indeed uh there you go what does it say
what does it say
painted by green sever
oh look at that this is fantastic
artwork
all right worth a lot of money that's
actually that's true actually
well we have we have worth a lot of cash
worth a lot of gas
already really need this benefactor
except that in you of the orb hey wait a
minute you only have one thing left
right
really you have to cut myself again once
more that's okay then we can get out of
here
yes and we can get out of here we get
blood left if they find the orb they get
to get the update all right so let them
find the order
all right okay all right one more time
one time which one is that that would be
uh i would imagine secrets offer
information though the conscious mind
grasps out
okay all right here we go
okay the conscious mind grasps out
and seldom finds a veiling mist
a steering kind yet nothing of substance
to bind
that that knife is really bloody now
yeah
yeah maybe i should take it with me as a
souvenir
all right well we put the blood back in
him dude are we going to do this
i can do a little incantation that's the
last one right all right
okay good luck
okay let's go oh my god oh my god it's
this is what we need yes it's the orb
finally
you did it you found the ore i got the
orf
yeah look at this
nice uh excellent uh look at that happy
faces
high five don't highlight with firing
that that would be safe
uh high five what's happening what's
going on what's happening all right
i'm gonna put the i'm gonna put the orb
away right out of here
uh okay anything going on nothing yeah
nothing
all right um i think we got it um i
think we have a problem
what's the problem um
[Music]
are you feeling a little bit happy yeah
sparring
[Music]
quickly use the
[Music]
what kind of a wizard are you saying
clearly there's
something going on with the magic
defense
it's impossible is this an anti-magic
field that doesn't exist nobody would
put an anti-magic field in the game
nobody does these things anymore
this is 2021. is right but i'm afraid
like it is an antidepressant oh my god
why did this light up
what is this what is this oh it's like a
sausage tree most likely
it's the leg of a devil okay so yeah
sure you're dying and you're gonna go
because this is a to the an angel all
right
oh come on you got to be quick man we
can't breathe here yeah oh
the hand of a kid sarai okay what else
do you see what else do you see
quickly yeah here we go there's some
rooms here
we've
[Music]
all right okay we'll do this together
with chat we're doing schedule chat chat
we got a uh what was it a leg of a devil
which plane would be a leg of a devil
just tell me leg of a devil leg of a
devil
the leg of a devil they're saying what
are they saying
the astral plane for the leg of a devil
they're saying avernus
nine health nine house nine houses
winning nine
[Music]
it fits all right excellent chat all
right what else do you have the angel
we got we got the headline angel angel
chat angel
where does an angel belong what what
which one
no the angels well some angels belong in
hell uh but i see celestia
pop up mount celestia actually on
celestia you got a mountain yeah all
right chad is very well educated
it is celestial plane
planes it fits as well all right and
then
we have the kids arriving all right
yeah i wish that was the hand of vac now
let's go all right
it's right our frog where are the kids
derived from
from the astral plane then they're
they're saying astral
uh some um i'm i i'm seeing okay that's
converging through
converging to they're converting
quickly sorry oh yeah my chat is not
agreeing
okay where's limbo where's limbo limbo
well there's a lot of limbs there so
like one of them is gonna be called
limbo all right limbo
there you go there you go what does that
do what does that do it fits perfectly
all right it's not doing anything oh
what are they glowing they're glowing
the anti-magic feels it's turning off
it's turning off
oh wait hold on who has the orp
the orb isn't in the inventory okay good
all right
so you've got the spell read the spell
rate the spell read it kelly
read it wait me yeah read it cute
i don't know this stuff you should take
it
take it because you got the inventory
and it only works for one person
what are you kidding me invader what no
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
oh it's you
i guess you really wanted this thing
[Music]
yours was a most noble sacrifice
it might have even changed the world
[Music]
[Music]
well done chat well done indeed
you guided our party who is standing
here come over here guys
oh our party of adventurers of
developers
who were so brave to brave the castle of
gustaf on dragonfell
you did a fantastic job and now you will
be able to continue doing your fantastic
job and playing at the early access
version of baldur's gate 3.
indeed you saw shadow hard there because
that is an other little piece of extra
content that we dropped you are going to
discover there's a bunch of new
permutations in the game
a little bit of extra new content maybe
a bit more than you expected
uh for you to discover um
we are going to show you the update this
is going to be it for us
you are fantastic we love you all you
are the fuel
in our hearts that makes us make this
game as good as we can
we still have a lot of work we know you
want a lot of content we want to make
the full game
we want to make it as good as possible
so we're going to take our time
so don't be too impatient with us but it
is coming to you
piece by piece and it gets better and
better take care everybody
and until next time and here comes that
update for you bye bye
hello everybody my name is fen vince i
am the director on vaults gate three
and i'm gonna talk you through today uh
all of the cool things that we've added
to bg3
in patch five so let's get started
one of the highlights for me of patch 5
is the inclusion of what we call the
active roll system
how does it work well it's very simple
whenever there's a check that pops up
you can actually ask your character to
cast a spell to eight fate a little bit
so for instance here you can see me cast
guidance and that's gonna give me a one
to four bonus on the role that i need to
do
but you could also ask one of the other
party members in your vicinity
to cast a spell to aid your luck a
little bit
and like this you can stack them and
that can make a very big difference in
gameplay to give you an example
i was playing the game uh earlier today
and
i was accessing the chapel there's a a
lockpick check that you can do there
and usually that fails because it has a
very high dc number it has a 20
which you need to match that's very high
but with the eight
of my cleric shadow heart i managed
actually to
open that door something that i hadn't
managed without cheats in a long time
and so i discovered a completely
different way of entering that chapel
and i was very happy to see also
that our scriptures and the writers had
anticipated all of that and had a
completely different entry point
to my adventure so be sure to try out
the active role when you download patch
5
you're going to find that it does quite
a lot of good things
go
hello next up is actually a pretty big
feature
which is the background balls when you
create a character in the game you get
to pick a background so you get to be a
full hero for instance or a novel
well say that you pick folk hero and you
do something that a folk hero would do
in the game then the game is going to
reward you with an inspiration point or
with some experience if you already
are at your inspiration gap which is
actually also a new thing
but you're gonna find that there's over
a hundred of these goals that were added
in the content of early access
for you to discover and every single
time you're gonna discover one of them
you're going to see them listed up here
in this neat handy background goal
ui that was added to the game it rises
from the stone
hanging in the air in silent offering
something that you have been asking us
for and something that we actually were
planning for
quite some time is the ability to free
shadow heart
in the tutorial in the past you couldn't
free her but now you can you don't have
to
it's up to you what you do with it but
you can free her and you'll notice that
that introduced a whole bunch of new
permutations to the story
as you'll try out to play the early
access content
you're alive we also added something
that was also
a very big community ask and which took
quite some effort to do because we're
trying to do it right
it is what we call the point and click
system it's very simple
whenever you're going to click somewhere
your characters are now going to
say something just like they did in the
original games
so for instance if i ask shadowhart to
walk somewhere she'll say this
he must keep going but if i ask her to
go into sneak mode
she'll save this unseen as i was taught
now the really cool part about this is
that they will change what they say in
function of where you are in the story
and where you are
on their character arcs depending on
what decisions you make
for early access alone we actually
recorded for each of them over 800
voice bars and we're gonna be recording
much more as we finish obviously
the entire thing need to keep focused
by popular demand we split up the uh
jump
and disengage this was in the past uh
jumping equal disengage and now we have
a separate disengage action and jump in
its own thing uh this is popular demand
also from community
uh you can now break concentration
there's a little
icon there that you can click on
whenever a character is concentrated if
you want to break their concentration
if you're a pacifist player you don't
necessarily need to kill
everybody anymore you can just toggle
the non legal attacks if you then start
smacking them
you're gonna knock them unconscious so
you can still rob them blind you don't
have to kill them it's better for your
karma
mini camps mini camps many camps are
super cool okay so
mini camps is essentially the feature
that when you go to sleep somewhere
the background setting of your camp is
gonna match the place where you go to
sleep
remember how in the past when you go to
sleep you were always in the wilderness
always with the forest background
well no more because if you now go to
sleep into the underdark
you're gonna be in the underdark if you
go to sleep into the chapel you're gonna
be in the chapel you go to sleep in the
cavern guess what you're gonna be in the
cavern it's fantastic it's really adds a
lot to the immersion of your adventure
took a lot of work because we had to
modify all the cinematics to be able to
take place wherever you were
but it was definitely worth it so it
adds a lot uh to the gameplay
you did it you're channeling the weave
speaking of camp again uh there's a
couple of extra cinematics that you'll
find in camp
uh definitely check out scratch and the
bear if you ever figure out how you can
get and the dog and the albert cup
into your camp it's possible then you're
going to have a very adorable scene as
baldur's gate 3 continues to improve its
bet simulating skills
we've added a new feature that we want
to try out during early access and it's
called camp resources
so uh what it means if you go to sleep
now
you're going to be asked what you want
to eat and if you eat sufficient you're
going to have a very
fruitful rest and you're going to
restore all of your spell slots and
all of your hp if you are for instance a
wizard
however if you don't have enough
supplies you will have what we call a
shallow rest and you're going to be able
to restore
everything the reason we did it is
because we want to differentiate
stronger between short
rest and long rest and so we're very
curious to see how it's going to play
for you so do
let us know what you think of our camp
supplies system
it definitely adds a lot to finding food
in the world and
you will notice that as you continue
playing the game the
cost of uh going to rest is going to
increase as you level up
and that actually reflects the the
growing upkeep of your ever increasing
uh camp in the game so very curious to
see uh what you're gonna do with that
and we'll fill your front with arrows
or you turn around and your backside
gets the same treatment
a strange symbol glows marked on their
flesh
and something within you stirs in
response
and there is a lot more now i'm not
going to go through the list of
everything uh there's just too much but
i do want to share a story
uh with you of how this patch changed my
own gameplay experience and i was really
happy with what i saw
so i already mentioned to you that uh
using my active role i actually managed
to open that chapel door something which
i hadn't done in a long time
so i went inside and as i went inside
uh i had some traps to deal with and i
had a little fight that i needed to do
and then i went to sleep and as i went
to sleep i had enough supplies so i ate
my supplies
and i was super happy to see that i was
actually standing
inside of the chapel as i went uh to
sleep
rather than being in that wilderness it
just felt right
and then when i walked outside of the
chapel and i surprised those bandits
that are there something that you
usually don't see because typically you
would go
from the other side and just meet the
bandits in their normal default script
setting
they reacted to it i saw a scene that i
hadn't seen in a long time there was a
guy yelling at me
hey somebody's coming out of the crypt
and i was feeling like
hey this is how it should be it's a
small thing but it was important to me
so i wanted to share it with you because
this is uh essentially the incremental
nature of development
things are starting to come together and
as they're starting to come together
we can start seeing the light at the end
of the tunnel of development where the
game eventually is going to be released
so i hope that when you're going to try
patch 5 you're going to have the same
conclusion because it is
actually getting a lot better
you